Like I think honestly, this is your best work, Bryce. It's your best work maybe of your career. And because CUDA, let's be honest, has a lot of work to do when it comes to its onboarding and education experience. And I think that this is the start of something beautiful. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 227 recorded on March 20th 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce I ask him questions about his GTC 2025 2025 talk entitled the CUDA C++ developers toolbox and more. One, two, three, four, five screenshots, five screenshots.
老实说，Bryce，我认为这是你最棒的作品。这可能是你职业生涯中最棒的作品。因为说实话，CUDA 在入门和教育体验方面还有很多工作要做。我认为这是一个美好事物的开端。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 227 期，录制于 2025 年 3 月 20 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，向他询问关于他在 GTC 2025 的演讲，题目是《CUDA C++ 开发者工具箱及更多内容》。一、二、三、四、五张截图，五张截图。
So not eight or nine, but definitely the most I've taken of any other talk I've watched is one, which leads me to, I mean, I'm not gonna screen share because we don't need to. You'll know the slides I'm talking about and maybe we'll include it in the show notes. By far, my favorite slide, arguably better than Jensen's equivalent folks. And Jensen said it was his favorite slide
所以不是八张或九张，但这绝对是我看过的所有演讲中截图最多的一次，只有一张，这让我想到了——我的意思是，我不会共享屏幕，因为没必要。你会知道我说的是哪张幻灯片，也许我们会把它放在节目笔记里。到目前为止，这是我最喜欢的幻灯片，可以说比 Jensen 的同类幻灯片还要好，伙计们。而且 Jensen 说这是他最喜欢的幻灯片。
if you watch the keynote. And Jensen, if you're listening to this for some reason, your slide was beautiful too, but for the discussion that's about to ensue, you'll understand why I like this one better. It is the four by six grid of logos of libraries. And this is why I've been up, I've lost sleep. I think I've had like four or five hours of sleep.
如果你看了主题演讲的话。Jensen，如果你因为某种原因在听这个节目，你的幻灯片也很漂亮，但对于接下来要进行的讨论，你会明白为什么我更喜欢这一张。这是一个 4x6 的库图标网格。这就是我一直没睡好的原因。我想我大概只睡了四五个小时。
I couldn't get to sleep for like an hour. I woke up at another point in the night, like couldn't get back to sleep for an hour because all I am doing is thinking about this slide deck. First of all, where did you get all the logos from? Oh man, so much work went into that slide. I know, I know. I saw the slide and I've never, I've lost sleep over this slide. So just so that the listener is not like, what are they talking about? We've got a four by six grid on a single slide of 24 different libraries. And we'll list off a couple.
我有一个小时睡不着。我在夜里又醒了一次，大概有一个小时没法入睡，因为我满脑子都在想这张幻灯片。首先，你从哪弄来的所有图标？天哪，那张幻灯片花了很多心血。我知道，我知道。我看到那张幻灯片时，我从来没有——我因为这张幻灯片失眠了。所以为了让听众不至于一头雾水，我们在一张幻灯片上有一个 4x6 的网格，包含了 24 个不同的库。我们会列举几个。
Thrust, Libku++, Rapids, KooFFT, KooTensor, KooDNN, Cub, Cutlass, etc. Some of them have logos. Some of them have modified versions of their logos to make it look better. Some of them just have text. Anyways, and I haven't seen most of these logos. We do have to clarify that they are not logos. They are graphic signifiers. All right, fantastic. This is exactly what I was hoping to get into. Some of them are logos. Thrust? Is thrust a logo? That's a logo.
Thrust、Libcu++、Rapids、cuFFT、cuTensor、cuDNN、Cub、Cutlass 等等。其中一些有图标。有些有修改过的图标版本，看起来更好看。有些只有文字。总之，我还没见过大部分这些图标。我们必须澄清它们不是图标（logos）。它们是图形标识符（graphic signifiers）。好吧，太棒了。这正是我想要深入探讨的内容。其中一些是图标。Thrust？Thrust 是图标吗？那是图标。
It is a graphic signifier. Okay, none of these are logos. Even rapids? Rapids doesn't count? Nope. They're all graphic signifiers. All right, I'm sure that's for some legal reason that I'm not involved. But walk me through what went into this slide. So none of these are official logos. Why do some of them don't have graphics? Where did you get these graphics from?
它是图形标识符。好吧，这些都不是图标。连 Rapids 也不算？不算。它们都是图形标识符。好吧，我相信这是出于某种我没参与的法律原因。但请带我了解一下这张幻灯片背后的制作过程。所以这些都不是官方图标。为什么有些没有图形？你从哪弄来的这些图形？
Was AI involved? Yeah, so actually, AI was involved, but the place where AI was involved was actually a different place with those graphic signifiers. The place where I used AI most heavily was on the slide introducing Thrust and Cub, where I list the four different kinds of things that are in Thrust and Cub. And there's a little graphic signifier for each one.
有 AI 参与吗？是的，实际上 AI 确实参与了，但 AI 参与的地方实际上与那些图形标识符是不同的。我最频繁使用 AI 的地方是在介绍 Thrust 和 Cub 的幻灯片上，我列出了 Thrust 和 Cub 中的四种不同类型的东西。每一个都有一个小图形标识符。
And those were all generated by O1, although it required me holding a baseball bat over the model. It's an interesting question of why would I generate images with a large language model, right? Like what shouldn't show it, let me put it differently. There are large language models specifically designed for generating images. There's one I've used in the past, I forget the name of it. I did not use one of those models and the reason I did not use one of those
它们都是由 O1 生成的，尽管这需要我拿着棒球棍对着模型（施压）。一个有趣的问题是，为什么我要用大语言模型来生成图像，对吧？比如不应该展示它，让我换个说法。有一些专门用于生成图像的大语言模型。我过去用过一个，我忘了它的名字。我没有使用那些模型，我没有使用那些模型的原因是
models is because I wanted to generate very simple vector graphic images. In particular, I wanted to generate SVGs. And so I viewed this as being more of a coding problem than a image generation problem. And so I thought it would be better to use something like O1 or Claude. I just used O1 because convenience, that seems to be the day to day model that I use for things.
因为我想生成非常简单的矢量图形图像。特别是，我想生成 SVG。所以我认为这更像是一个编码问题，而不是图像生成问题。所以我认为使用像 O1 或 Claude 这样的工具会更好。我只是用了 O1，因为方便，这似乎是我日常使用的模型。
So I had it generate those SVGs and it took a bit of back and forth. I wanted them in a specific color scheme which it was able to do, but then things like, I told it like make it 200 by 200 SVG and it would make something but it would put padding around it, right? So that what I want in these little graphic signifiers is I want either in the horizontal or vertical dimension of the graphic, I wanted to touch the boundaries because I'll add padding myself. And it took a little work to convince it that actually I know I don't want any padding. And there was a bunch of iteration back and forth of getting it, like one of the mistakes it made frequently was it would get the
所以我让它生成了那些 SVG，经过了一些来回的修改。我想要特定的配色方案，它能够做到，但后来像——我告诉它制作 200x200 的 SVG，它会制作出来，但会在周围加上填充，对吧？所以我想要这些小图形标识符的是，我希望在图形的水平或垂直维度上，它能触及边界，因为我会自己添加填充。说服它我确实不需要任何填充花了一些功夫。经过了一连串的反复迭代，比如它经常犯的一个错误是它会把
the layering wrong so like the if there's some of these graphic signifiers have arrows and dots like like dots and then arrows going between them and sometimes it would have the arrows be on the layer in front of the dots so you'd see the start of the arrow like in the middle of the dot and like it doesn't look good. And I would be like, no, put them in this order. And I was surprised that if I told it a complex instruction like have the dots in front of the arrows, and then the
图层弄错，所以如果这些图形标识符中有箭头和点，比如点，然后箭头在它们之间穿过，有时它会把箭头放在点前面的图层上，所以你会看到箭头的起点在点的中间，看起来不太好。我会说，不，按这个顺序放。我很惊讶，如果我给它一个复杂的指令，比如让点在箭头前面，然后
arrows in front of the other element, and then the other element in front of this, it kind of got the idea. And then the logos on that page that you saw, so some of them come from, some of them have like all the CUDA math libraries have their own little graphics signifier, those are the ones on the left and they, I love those because they have a very nice uniform style. And for slideware, I love having these simple vector graphic images. And I've been trying to think about how do I describe the property of what I'm looking for in the slide graphic and I think it's like one
箭头在另一个元素前面，然后另一个元素在它前面，它大概理解了意思。然后你看到的页面上的那些图标，所以其中一些来自——有些像所有的 CUDA 数学库都有它们自己的小图形标识符，那些是左边的，我喜欢它们，因为它们有一种非常统一的风格。对于幻灯片制作，我喜欢这些简单的矢量图形图像。我一直在思考如何描述我在幻灯片图形中寻找的属性，我想就像
I'm not looking I want something with no shading, no like shadows or anything like that sometimes they're 3D sometimes they're 2D usually it's like a 2D flat perspective I usually use very few colors. And I want it to be a vector graphic so that I can scale it and have it look very nice. And I want it to be simple.
我不寻找——我想要没有阴影、没有投影之类的东西，有时它们是 3D 的，有时是 2D 的，通常是 2D 平面视角。我通常使用很少的颜色。我希望它是矢量图形，这样我可以缩放它，让它看起来非常漂亮。而且我希望它很简单。
And one of the reasons that I like it to be simple is because if it's simple, then I can make it as small or as large as I want. And I don't have to worry about there being a loss of the detail of it. Some of the libraries didn't have a graphic signifiers, some of the libraries didn't have graphic signifiers and I just made the graphic signifier like that little one for NVBench did not exist, did not exist a week ago.
我喜欢它简单的原因之一是，如果它很简单，那么我可以把它做得尽可能小或尽可能大。我不必担心细节丢失。有些库没有图形标识符，有些库没有图形标识符，我就自己做了图形标识符，比如那个 NVBench 的小图标，一周前还不存在。
And then some of them like the cuDNN and the tensorRT ones NvBench did not exist a week ago. And then some of them, like the cuDNN and the tensorRT ones, I found there was a blog post where there was on cuDNN, and there was a blog post on tensorRT. And those are not official logos for those libraries. But the blog post had a nice image that was at the header of the blog post. It was an official NVIDIA blog post.
然后有些像 cuDNN 和 TensorRT 的，NVBench 一周前还不存在。然后有些，像 cuDNN 和 TensorRT 的，我发现有一篇博客文章里有 cuDNN，还有一篇关于 TensorRT 的博客文章。那些不是这些库的官方图标。但博客文章在页眉处有一张漂亮的图片。那是官方的 NVIDIA 博客文章。
And I was like, this is a nicer way than just putting the Kudian in text up on the slide. So yeah, and in at least a couple of these libraries, I just went to the person who maintains the library. And I'm like, hey, look, your library is going to be on this slide. Do you have a graphic signifier that you want me to use? And I think the next time I give this talk,
我就想，这比直接在幻灯片上放 cuDNN 文字要好。所以是的，至少在其中几个库中，我直接去找了维护该库的人。我说，嘿，看，你的库会出现在这张幻灯片上。你有什么想要我使用的图形标识符吗？我想下次我做这个演讲时，
there will be more of these that will actually have graphic signifiers and not just text. Because at least one person promised me that they would create the graphic signifier. And I didn't have a chance to check back in with them. But they have an idea of what it would look like. We just haven't produced it yet. But I know how much you, Connor, love having programming
会有更多这样的库拥有图形标识符，而不仅仅是文字。因为至少有一个人答应我会创建图形标识符。我还没来得及跟进。但他们对它看起来的样子有个想法。我们只是还没制作出来。但我知道你，Connor，有多喜欢编程
language logos. And I was talking with some people internally about this. So CUDA C++ does not have a programming language logo. And one of the points that I made to people is that I think the best programming language logos and the best graphic signifiers in general are the ones where you don't have to put text below it to say what it is. Like the C++ logo, the C logo, the Fortran logo, you don't have
语言图标。我曾与内部的一些人讨论过这个问题。所以 CUDA C++ 没有编程语言图标。我向人们提出的观点之一是，我认为最好的编程语言图标和最好的图形标识符通常是那些你不需要在下面加文字说明它是什么的。比如 C++ 图标、C 图标、Fortran 图标，你不需要
to put the text below it saying that it's C++ or Fortran or C. Now the Python logo doesn't, like, if you have no familiarity, you're not going to know. But I feel like Python is ubiquitous enough that maybe it's not a problem I don't know about the like the rest logo Like maybe it's fine But the ones that I like best for programming languages are the ones where you can even if you don't know The logo you can tell what the programming language is. I Mean I've got so many so many so many thoughts and follow-up questions and this is clearly Gonna turn into two parts. So maybe the start of my questions was part two of this episode
在下面加文字说它是 C++、Fortran 或 C。现在 Python 图标没有——如果你不熟悉，你不会知道。但我感觉 Python 已经足够普及了，也许这不是个问题。我不知道 Rust 图标怎么样，也许没问题。但我最喜欢的编程语言图标是那些即使你不认识这个图标，也能看出它是哪种编程语言的。我的意思是，我有太多太多的想法和后续问题了，这显然会变成两部分。所以也许我问题的开始是这一集的第二部分。
So you got the gtc recap which probably was only 25 minutes But at this point this is gonna blow way past the 35 minute like max one episode And i'm about to twi i'm about to twi i'm about to tweet low on sleep folks I I did mention I lost sleep over this slide and I still got other questions to get to Um, i'm about to tweet, with your permission, Jensen versus Bryce slide deck. Is that fine? I'm not gonna add Jensen. That's fine. I'm just gonna pretend that I didn't hear you ask me the question. All right, but it needs to be done mostly, I mean, I don't need to put Jensen versus Bryce
所以你有 GTC 回顾，可能只有 25 分钟，但现在这会远远超过 35 分钟的单集上限，我正要——我正要——我正要发推特说我睡眠不足，伙计们。我确实提到了我因为这张幻灯片失眠了，我还有其他问题要问。嗯，我正要发推特，经你允许，Jensen 对比 Bryce 的幻灯片。可以吗？我不加 Jensen。没关系。我就假装没听见你问我这个问题。好吧，但它需要完成，主要是，我的意思是，我不需要放 Jensen 对比 Bryce
slide deck. It's just this slide that I'm talking about versus the one because do you know the slide that I'm referring to in Jensen's talk that actually then I don't need to tweet it. But now that I said I will, I will because I needed you to and actually it probably will be good. So head to Twitter. I'm about to tweet this right now. Actually, should I just put Jensen versus Bryce?
的幻灯片。只是我提到的这张幻灯片对比那一张，因为你知道我指的是 Jensen 演讲中的哪张幻灯片吗？实际上那我不需要发推特了。但既然我说我会发，我就会发，因为我需要你这样做，而且实际上这可能很好。所以去 Twitter 吧。我正要发推特。实际上，我应该只写 Jensen 对比 Bryce 吗？
No commentary. People can infer what they want. And once you're at Twitter, and this is why I've lost so much sleep, I'm about to explain. So once again, for the audio listener, Jensen's slide is, we will say, much more consistent in that every single one of the, what I'll assume is a cell phone screen with some artistic art on it, it looks roughly the same. Unlike Bryce's slide, there are no missing graphics signifiers. That being said, they're also way less meaningful
不加评论。人们可以推断他们想推断的内容。一旦你到了 Twitter——这就是我失眠的原因，我正要解释。所以再次说明，对于音频听众，Jensen 的幻灯片，我们说，更一致，因为每一个——我假设是手机屏幕，上面有一些艺术画——看起来大致相同。不像 Bryce 的幻灯片，没有缺失的图形标识符。话虽如此，它们也远没有那么有意义，
because these are all just artistic art things that have nothing to do with the actual underlying technologies. And on top of that, it does some weird things or weird or it's maybe the future. All of the cu prefix libraries are followed by uppercase letters, which is not the case in your slide deck. Which is also not the way that these libraries are named. But at least on Jensen's slide that is the case. And...
因为这些都只是与实际底层技术无关的艺术画。最重要的是，它做了一些奇怪的事情，或者奇怪，或者这可能是未来。所有 cu 前缀的库后面都跟着大写字母，这在你的幻灯片中不是这样。这也不是这些库的命名方式。但至少在 Jensen 的幻灯片上是这样。而且……
So, I have slightly mixed feelings about that. I, you know, the math, I do feel like we ought to be consistent in the style and the spelling. And the math libraries all consistently do cu and all uppercase letters now. And I think part of that is because cu-blas, which is one of the first ones, cu-blas and cu-f-f FFT were the first two CUDA libraries. Well, BLAS is an acronym and FFT is an acronym. So I think that started the trend. And then originally Coup Solver, which solver is not an acronym, solver is a word, Coup
所以，我对此有种复杂的感觉。我，你知道，数学库，我确实觉得我们应该在风格和拼写上保持一致。所有的数学库现在都统一使用 cu 和大写字母。我认为部分原因是 cuBLAS，它是最早的库之一，cuBLAS 和 cuFFT 是最早的两个 CUDA 库。好吧，BLAS 是缩写，FFT 是缩写。所以我认为这开启了这一趋势。最初 cuSolver，Solver 不是缩写，Solver 是一个词，cu
Solver was originally Coup capital S and then lowercase the rest of solver. And the same for Coo sparse. There were periods of times where it was spelled differently. But I think that for consistency with the Coo Blas, the Coo FFT, the Coo DSS, that it became this way. I mean, that's fair enough. I completely agree that we should this way. I mean, that's fair enough. I completely agree that we should be consistent. I'm just merely pointing out that there's a delta. And one of the biggest things that I've lost sleep over
Solver 最初是 cu 大写 S，其余小写。cuSparse 也一样。曾经有一段时间拼写不同。但我认为为了与 cuBLAS、cuFFT、cuDSS 保持一致，它变成了这样。我的意思是，这很公平。我完全同意我们应该这样。我的意思是，这很公平。我完全同意我们应该保持一致。我只是指出有一个差异。我失眠的最大原因之一
is the fact that on your slide, Rapids is there. And one, first of all, Rapids is purple and... I'm gonna get in so much trouble. I'm gonna get in so much trouble. I mean, it's there and it's been greenified. I don't necessarily, I'm not too upset by the fact that it's been greenified because you want to make the slide look nice. If it was purple it would look awful. But on Jensen's version of the slide, he doesn't mention Rapids. He just puts cuDF and cuML which is, and so for folks outside of Nvidia not familiar with Rapids,
是你的幻灯片上有 Rapids。而且，首先，Rapids 是紫色的，而且……我会惹上大麻烦的。我会惹上大麻烦的。我的意思是，它在那里，而且被“绿色化”了。我不一定——我并不太介意它被绿色化，因为你想让幻灯片看起来好看。如果是紫色的，看起来会很糟糕。但在 Jensen 的幻灯片版本中，他没有提到 Rapids。他只放了 cuDF 和 cuML，所以对于 NVIDIA 之外不熟悉 Rapids 的人来说，
which is where I started my So for folks outside of Nvidia not familiar with Rapids, which is where I started my Nvidia career on the Rapids team before switching to research, is Rapids is basically an umbrella term for a bunch of these libraries, which include QDF. QDF is also an acronym for DataFrame, which is the Pandas equivalent, and ML for machine learning. And it's kind of, the reason I've lost sleep is that it is indicative of this kind of, I don't wanna say marketing problem,
这是我开始我的——所以对于 NVIDIA 之外不熟悉 Rapids 的人来说，这是我开始我的 NVIDIA 职业生涯的地方，在转到研究部门之前是在 Rapids 团队，Rapids 基本上是这一堆库的总称，其中包括 cuDF。cuDF 也是 DataFrame 的缩写，它是 Pandas 的等价物，ML 代表机器学习。这有点——我失眠的原因是这表明了这种——我不想说是营销问题，
but like, and also too, there was another slide from the Python talk where they show this graphic of all the different Python technologies of which Nvidia was not a part of. It shows PyCuda in 2010, then Numba, KooPy, PyTorch, Jax, and then Rapids Warp, KudaPython, and Triton Lang. Rapids Warp and KudaPython being only the NVIDIA-built projects. All the other ones were outside, which I thought was kind of curious that for the first decade NVIDIA didn't have any direct ownership over these projects.
但就像，还有，Python 演讲中还有另一张幻灯片，他们展示了所有不同 Python 技术的图形，其中 NVIDIA 并不在其中。它显示了 2010 年的 PyCUDA，然后是 Numba、cuPy、PyTorch、Jax，然后是 Rapids、Warp、cuPython 和 Triton Lang。Rapids、Warp 和 cuPython 是仅有的 NVIDIA 构建的项目。所有其他的都在外部，我觉得这有点奇怪，因为在第一个十年里，NVIDIA 对这些项目没有任何直接所有权。
But that, I'm not sure about warp because I actually haven't used it, but I believe Rapids requires Conda at the moment. KooPy numeric requires Conda, whereas like Jax and PyTorch, you can just pip install. And anyway, so there's just this, what do you call it? Like disconnect of like, you do you call it? Like disconnect of like, you've got in the first two verticals, all the coup libraries, and then you've got
但那个，我不确定 Warp，因为我实际上没用过它，但我相信 Rapids 目前需要 Conda。cuPy numeric 需要 Conda，而像 Jax 和 PyTorch，你可以直接 pip install。总之，所以这里只是有这个，你称之为什么？就像断层，你称之为什么？就像断层，你在前两列垂直方向上有所有的 cu 库，然后你有
rapids, which is kind of like an umbrella for a bunch of coup. So I'm getting to my question. What are your thoughts and feelings about this? Yeah, so you know, I actually, so one, I do have to say, I liked Jensen's slide. And I think that his slide and my slide are trying to do different things, because they're trying to speak to different people. My slide and my talk is targeting purely a developer audience.
Rapids，它有点像一堆 cu 的总称。所以我正要问我的问题。你对此有什么想法和感受？是的，所以你知道，我实际上——第一，我必须说，我喜欢 Jensen 的幻灯片。我认为他的幻灯片和我的幻灯片试图做不同的事情，因为它们试图对不同的人说话。我的幻灯片和我的演讲目标纯粹是开发者受众。
And Jensen's speaking to not just developers, but also people who are in these particular industries. He's speaking to analysts, to everybody who cares about GPUs. And I think that his slide is far more effective for a broader audience. But I also I love that despite the fact that Jensen's got a much wider audience that he has to speak to, that he's still able to have a talk that's so developer focused. I think it's great that he's still got a talk where he's got a slide there where he calls
而 Jensen 不仅在对开发者说话，也在对这些特定行业的人说话。他在对分析师说话，对所有关心 GPU 的人说话。我认为他的幻灯片对于更广泛的受众来说更有效。但我同时也喜欢，尽管 Jensen 必须面对更广泛的受众，但他仍然能够进行一场如此专注于开发者的演讲。我觉得很棒的是，他仍然有一个演讲，其中有一张幻灯片，他提到了
out and speaks about a lot of the great libraries that we built. That's I think really special. I think there's not a lot of tech CEOs who will talk about, you know, developer libraries, like specific developer libraries that their company's building. So I actually was kind of excited by Jensen's slide. I debated whether I should, and I actually, I think if I had had time, I would have taken Rapids off of my slide and I would have put cootie up there instead. It's not solely because of the purple logo nature of Rapids.
并谈论了我们构建的许多伟大的库。我认为这真的很特别。我认为没有多少科技公司 CEO 会谈论，你知道，开发者库，比如他们公司正在构建的特定开发者库。所以我实际上对 Jensen 的幻灯片感到有点兴奋。我纠结过我是否应该——实际上，我想如果我有时间，我会把 Rapids 从我的幻灯片上拿掉，我会把 cuDF 放上去。这不仅仅是因为 Rapids 紫色图标的原因。
It's because Rapids isn't a library. Rapids is a collection of libraries and to some degree it's more of product. I wanted this slide to be not product focused, but library focused. Like the point of my talk was to, or the point of this slide in my talk was to point people to all the tools that are available to them. And so I think that when I give this talk in the future,
这是因为 Rapids 不是一个库。Rapids 是一个库集合，在某种程度上它更像是一个产品。我希望这张幻灯片不是以产品为中心，而是以库为中心。我的演讲重点是，或者我演讲中这张幻灯片的重点是向人们指出所有可供他们使用的工具。所以我认为当我将来做这个演讲时，
I'll probably instead of rapids just have cootie-f there. The problem is there's not enough real estate in the slide for me to do what I would really want which would be to list all of the various Rapids libraries, of which there are many. But maybe what I would do is I would take off one or two of the math libraries and put some of the Rapids libraries up there too. Well, I'm thinking of like this slide, I know because I know you will clearly evolve over time and the iterations that you give this talk. But like I think, you know, one of the questions
我可能会用 cuDF 代替 Rapids。问题是幻灯片上没有足够的空间让我做我真正想做的事情，即列出所有各种 Rapids 库，其中有很多。但也许我会做的是，我会去掉一两个数学库，也放一些 Rapids 库上去。嗯，我在想这张幻灯片，我知道因为我知道你会随着时间的推移和演讲的迭代而不断演变。但就像我认为，你知道，演讲结束时的一个问题
at the end of the talk was about docs and, you know, best practices in terms of education, which CCCL and Nvidia is one of their primary focuses now. But what would be amazing is if like this was, there was a JavaScript, I don't know if you need D3 for the kind of animations that I'm thinking of, but like imagine this as a landing page website where you hover, you take your mouse and hover over these
是关于文档和，你知道，教育方面的最佳实践，这是 CCCL 和 NVIDIA 现在的主要重点之一。但如果这是一个 JavaScript，我不知道你是否需要 D3 来实现我正在想的那种动画，但想象一下这是一个着陆页网站，当你悬停时，你用鼠标悬停在这些上面，
and it does a little jiggle every time you go over each one and then for rapids, you would get this little balloon that expanded into QDF and QML. And it would be a good starting point of like, the other thing is too is, which is a whole other layer of this of like, what is the language that you are interrupting with? Technically Rapids at the highest level is Python, right?
它每次你经过每一个时都会轻微抖动，然后对于 Rapids，你会得到一个小气球，展开成 cuDF 和 cuML。这将是一个很好的起点，另一件事是，这是这一层的另一部分，即你正在与之交互的语言是什么？从技术上讲，Rapids 在最高层是 Python，对吧？
There are C plus, CUDA C plus plus libraries that you can target that lie beneath them. But it seems a bit odd to have Rapids sitting right on top of Thrust. I mean, actually it doesn't seem odd because have RAPIDS sitting right on top of Thrust. I mean, actually, it doesn't seem odd because RAPIDS is kind of built on top of Thrust, but like Thrust is a CUDA C++ library, whereas RAPIDS is primarily a C++ or a Python library that has C++ lower level libraries that you can target. Anyway, so depending on the, what do we call them, graphic signifier? You know, you have access to different languages
有一些 C++、CUDA C++ 库你可以定位，它们位于其下方。但让 Rapids 直接坐在 Thrust 之上似乎有点奇怪。我的意思是，实际上它看起来并不奇怪，因为让 RAPIDS 坐在 Thrust 之上。我的意思是，实际上它看起来并不奇怪，因为 RAPIDS 有点建立在 Thrust 之上，但就像 Thrust 是一个 CUDA C++ 库，而 RAPIDS 主要是一个 C++ 或 Python 库，它有你可以定位的 C++ 底层库。总之，取决于，我们称它们为什么？图形标识符？你知道，你对每个工具或每个库都有不同的语言访问权限。
per tool or per library. So the hardest part about this slide was figuring out the ordering and the grouping of these. And there's a couple different accesses upon which I needed to group them. First, there were libraries that do similar things. So there's, on the left hand side, there were libraries that do similar things. So there's, on the left hand side, there are eight libraries that are typically known as the CUDA math libraries. And then we have the three C++ core libraries, Thrust,coup++, and cobb. Then there's Envybench, which is maintained and developed by the C++ core libraries team,
所以这张幻灯片最难的部分是弄清楚它们的排序和分组。我需要根据几个不同的轴来对它们进行分组。首先，有做类似事情的库。所以，在左侧，有做类似事情的库。所以，在左侧，有八个通常被称为 CUDA 数学库的库。然后我们有三个 C++ 核心库，Thrust、libcu++ 和 Cub。然后是 NVBench，它由 C++ 核心库团队维护和开发，
but it's really, it's a benchmarking framework. I think of it more of like a developer tool. And then there's the CUDA runtime, which is what everything here is built on top of. Then some of these libraries are device side libraries. Some of these libraries are libraries where it's a thing that you call from your CPU that launches work on the GPU. Some of them are things that you purely use in device code on the GPU. And some of them are a mix of both. And so I try, like there's a couple on here, Cutlist, Cooperative Groups, and Cub. I needed those three to be next to each other.
但它实际上是一个基准测试框架。我更多地把它看作是一个开发者工具。然后是 CUDA 运行时，这里的一切都是建立在它之上的。然后其中一些库是设备端库。其中一些库是你从 CPU 调用并在 GPU 上启动工作的库。其中一些是你纯粹在 GPU 上的设备代码中使用的东西。其中一些是两者的混合。所以我尝试——这里有几个，Cutlass、Cooperative Groups 和 Cub。我需要这三个彼此相邻。
But also Cub needed to be near all the other CCCL libraries. But then the last constraint, and then there were libraries like Envy, Shrem, and Nickel, which are communication libraries that I wanted to have together and then like Coup files and IO library I wanted to have that near like the Coup to runtime and some of the other like like it's not a compute library there's one way of dividing these libraries is is it a library that does, you know, that does math or science or physics or is it a library that does like, you know, runtime management or, or comms or IO or stuff like that.
但 Cub 也需要靠近所有其他 CCCL 库。但最后一个约束，然后还有像 NVShmem 和 NCCL 这样的库，它们是通信库，我想要放在一起，然后像 cuFile 和 IO 库，我想要让它靠近像 CUDA 运行时和其他一些——就像它不是一个计算库，划分这些库的一种方法是，它是一个做数学、科学或物理的库，还是一个做运行时管理、通信、IO 之类的库。
And then there's the, the machine learning libraries, QDNN and TensorRT. And I wanted those three libraries to kind of be centered in the image. I decided that it was best for them to either be at the top or the bottom because I have four rows. If I had had three rows, I would have put them in the center row. But I feel like with four rows, that would have been hard. And I actually, the way I made this slide is I started off with just raw boxes and I figured out how many of these blank boxes did I want to have and then based on that I tried out different configurations and then I made the list of what things I was going to include.
然后是机器学习库，cuDNN 和 TensorRT。我想要那三个库在图像中居中。我决定最好让它们要么在顶部要么在底部，因为我有四行。如果我有三行，我会把它们放在中间行。但我觉得有四行的话，那会很难。我实际上制作这张幻灯片的方式是我从原始框开始，我弄清楚了我想有多少个空白框，然后基于此我尝试了不同的配置，然后我列出了我要包含的东西。
You know going off of that. Let me see if I can find the first version of this slide deck went through. It's on R4 right now. And the way that I version my slide decks is I bump to another R version of them when either I give the talk or if I delete content. Like if I change the content plan substantially, then I will make a new version of the slides because I want to record, I want to save what my old content plan was. I'm going to share my screen with you very briefly, but it's okay because the visual will be easy to explain. This is what the slide originally looked like where it was the four by six grid in a slightly different configuration and it is just boxes,
接着说。让我看看我能不能找到这张幻灯片的第一版。它现在是 R4 版本。我给幻灯片版本编号的方式是，当我做演讲或删除内容时，我会跳到另一个 R 版本。比如如果我大幅改变内容计划，那么我会制作一个新版本的幻灯片，因为我想记录，我想保存我旧的内容计划。我会非常简短地与你共享屏幕，但没关系，因为视觉效果很容易解释。这就是幻灯片最初的样子，它是一个配置略有不同的 4x6 网格，它只是框，
square boxes that say the library names and some of them have different colors to indicate the grouping and there's a giant like text box on the slide that says to do this but do better and I think I did better than the you know colored text boxes one hopes all right I mean I'll have to think on this but like I'm coming to realize the reason I have lost sleep and we're discussing this at length. And also I put the cart in front of the horse. I didn't even explain Bryce's talk, which I'm going to take a 10 second digression. The title of Bryce's talk was the CUDA C++ Developer's Toolbox.
方形框，上面写着库名称，有些有不同的颜色来表示分组，幻灯片上有一个巨大的文本框，上面写着“做这个，但做得更好”，我想我做得比那些彩色文本框要好，人们希望如此。好吧，我的意思是，我得考虑一下，但我开始意识到我失眠的原因，我们正在详细讨论这个问题。而且我本末倒置了。我甚至没有解释 Bryce 的演讲，我要花 10 秒钟离题一下。Bryce 演讲的题目是《CUDA C++ 开发者工具箱》。
It is at a high level showing some examples of Thrust, cub, and what was the other libcu++? You show that at all? libcu++, yeah. Yes. And then also it covers the universal vector, which I have a question about, which we'll get to. But anyways, high level, that's what it's about. I was supposed to say that at the beginning, but I got too excited about this slide.
它在高层展示了一些 Thrust、Cub 的例子，还有另一个 libcu++ 是什么？你展示了吗？libcu++，是的。是的。然后它还涵盖了通用向量，我有一个关于它的问题，我们稍后会讲到。但总之，高层来说，这就是它的内容。我本应该在开头说的，但我对这张幻灯片太兴奋了。
And the reason I've lost sleep, I think this is your best slide you've ever made, but it's going to be so much better. Like I think honestly, this is your best slide you've ever made but it's gonna be so much better. Like I think honestly this is your best work Bryce. It's your best work maybe of your career and because CUDA, let's be honest, has a lot of work to do when it comes to its onboarding and education experience. And I think that this is the start of something beautiful and so my recommendation, I already had this in my mind before you showed me what I'm looking at right now, which is I'm staring at six different colors.
我失眠的原因，我认为这是你做过的最好的幻灯片，但它会变得更好。就像我认为老实说，这是你做过的最好的幻灯片，但它会变得更好。就像我认为老实说，这是你最棒的作品，Bryce。这可能是你职业生涯中最棒的作品，因为 CUDA，说实话，在入门和教育体验方面还有很多工作要做。我认为这是一个美好事物的开端，所以我的建议，在你向我展示我现在看到的东西之前，我脑子里就已经有了这个想法，那就是我正盯着六种不同的颜色。
We've got yellow, red, blue, purple, pink, and green. When you were describing that on the two left columns of the six columns on this slide are the CUDA math libraries, I was thinking, man, what you should have added to that talk was like having a rounded, not pointy, but a rounded rectangle that kind of briefly goes over and says, these are the math libraries. And then that one disappears.
我们有黄色、红色、蓝色、紫色、粉色和绿色。当你描述这张幻灯片六列中的左两列是 CUDA 数学库时，我在想，伙计，你应该在演讲中添加的是——有一个圆角的，不是尖角的，而是圆角的矩形，简要地覆盖并说，这些是数学库。然后那个消失。
And then the next one pops up and that one has a red coloring. So basically have like six slides that transition and fade from like one rounded rectangle to another rounded rectangle that basically visually, and then you would vocally describe because I think to folks at Nvidia, you know, we see thrust next to libcu++ next to cub and and we know that like, okay You know thrust is is kind of a layer above cub and you know, it interacts with anyways We see the connections but for folks that are maybe even experienced or not experienced,
然后下一个弹出来，那个有红色着色。所以基本上有六张幻灯片，从一个圆角矩形过渡和淡入到另一个圆角矩形，基本上在视觉上，然后你会口头描述，因为我认为对于 NVIDIA 的人来说，你知道，我们看到 Thrust 旁边是 libcu++，旁边是 Cub，我们知道 Thrust 有点像 Cub 上面的一层，你知道，它与——总之，我们看到了连接，但对于那些可能经验丰富或不那么有经验的人来说，
those connections are invisible. They have no idea that this implicit grouping exists there. And also, they may also not know what these libraries are. And it's interesting that you say that because we talked a little bit earlier about that this is a 35-minute talk about that this is a 35 minute talk and this is a talk I plan to give a lot this year and for the most part speaking engagements are hour long talks. So the reality is the GTC version of this talk was really just a preview.
这些连接是不可见的。他们根本不知道这种隐式分组存在。而且，他们可能也不知道这些库是什么。你这么说很有趣，因为我们之前谈到过这是一个 35 分钟的演讲，这是一个我计划今年多做几次的演讲，而且大多数演讲邀请都是一小时的演讲。所以现实是，GTC 版本的演讲真的只是一个预览。
There is an hour long version of this talk and there was content that had to be cut and I think of the content that had to be cut. And I think of the content that had to be cut, the parts that are probably the most interesting to you is one, the reason I put so much effort into this slide is because this slide, something just like what you described, will happen with this slide. I haven't built that part of the deck yet, but I'm going to spend five to ten minutes going through this overview of the libraries and giving people the, not going to go into details, but giving people the pointers about what are these libraries, when should you use them?
有一个一小时版本的演讲，有一些内容必须被删减。我想被删减的内容，对你来说可能最有趣的部分是，第一，我在这张幻灯片上投入了这么多精力，因为这张幻灯片，就像你描述的那样，会发生在这张幻灯片上。我还没构建那部分幻灯片，但我会花 5 到 10 分钟来浏览这些库的概述，给人们——不深入细节，但给人们关于这些库是什么、什么时候应该使用它们的指针。
Because it's the CUDA C++ Developers Toolbox, the name of the talk. We want to teach people what are the tools in the toolbox. And the other thing that got sadly cut from this version of the talk is I spent some time talking about the by-key algorithms. And I was very sad to cut that from this talk because I think if you're looking at thrust versus the standard library algorithms, the part of thrust that's most compelling for
因为它是《CUDA C++ 开发者工具箱》，演讲的名字。我们想教人们工具箱里有什么工具。演讲的这个版本中遗憾地被删减的另一件事是，我花了一些时间谈论按键算法（by-key algorithms）。我很难过把它从这次演讲中删掉，因为我认为如果你在看 Thrust 和标准库算法，Thrust 最吸引人的部分是
people is that there's all these very useful extended algorithms. Like you could use C++ standard parallelism, which we have an implementation that supports GPU acceleration, but if you wanted to do a segmented reduction, that's not in standard C++ yet. And so I had a couple different examples of doing some nice segmented reductions that I had to trim. Those will be in the next version of this talk and also the deep dive and this or not the deep dive the overview of some of these libraries will be in the next version of this talk and I suspect that I will do something like
人们发现有很多非常有用的扩展算法。比如你可以使用 C++ 标准并行，我们有一个支持 GPU 加速的实现，但如果你想做一个分段归约（segmented reduction），那在标准 C++ 中还没有。所以我有一些不同的例子来做一些很好的分段归约，但我不得不删减。那些会出现在这个演讲的下一个版本中，深度解析——或者不是深度解析，这些库的概述也会出现在下一个版本中，我怀疑我会做一些像
what you described with the boxes. It'll probably just be like a like drawing a circle around these. And I actually like the idea that you just had about rapids, to have it expand out into all of the various rapids libraries. I should say this is the first time I've given a talk where I have used transitions and I used the morph words transition that Connor taught me about. But then I think that I maybe do this more than you because when I've seen you use the morph words transition, you usually do it on a pure code slide.
你描述的那样带有框的事情。它可能只是像在这些周围画一个圆圈。我实际上喜欢你刚才关于 Rapids 的想法，让它展开成所有各种 Rapids 库。我应该说这是我第一次在演讲中使用过渡，我使用了 Connor 教我的“变形文字”（morph words）过渡。但我认为我可能比你做得更多，因为当我看到你使用变形文字过渡时，你通常在纯代码幻灯片上使用它。
But I often have a code with diagrams slide side by side and I found that when I used morph words that it would fade the diagram to black and the reason is because PowerPoint in a lot of cases if I had the diagram, even if I had the same diagram on one side versus another slide, the group of objects would have a different name from slide to slide. So PowerPoint would get confused. But I learned that if you go into this magical thing called the selection pane in PowerPoint, you can give your group of objects a specific name. And if they have the same name from slide to slide, then the PowerPoint transitions know that they're the same thing.
但我经常有并排的代码和图表幻灯片，我发现当我使用变形文字时，它会把图表淡入黑色，原因是因为 PowerPoint 在很多情况下，如果我有图表，即使我在一张幻灯片和另一张幻灯片上有相同的图表，对象组在不同幻灯片上会有不同的名称。所以 PowerPoint 会感到困惑。但我了解到，如果你进入 PowerPoint 中这个神奇的“选择窗格”（selection pane），你可以给你的对象组一个特定的名称。如果它们在不同幻灯片上有相同的名称，那么 PowerPoint 过渡就知道它们是同一个东西。
And so that's how I was able to use that trick to build some really cool morph transitions. And I really love the morph transitions. For so long I resisted having transitions in my slides and part of it is that transitions take time and they can throw off by timing. Part of it is that if you rely heavily on transitions and animations in your slides then the PDF version of your slides, the like if somebody's just reading through your slides it can be a little bit harder. But I am a convert.
这就是我能够使用那个技巧来构建一些非常酷的变形过渡的方法。我真的很喜欢变形过渡。长期以来，我一直抵制在幻灯片中使用过渡，部分原因是过渡需要时间，它们会打乱时间安排。部分原因是如果你严重依赖幻灯片中的过渡和动画，那么 PDF 版本的幻灯片，比如如果有人只是阅读你的幻灯片，可能会有点困难。但我是一个皈依者。
I loved the morph words transition and to explain for people who don't know, that what the morph words transition does is, if you've got like two slides of text that are very similar, but there's some changes between the two, the morph words transition will, it will show the words, the text between the two slides, like evolving into each other.
我喜欢变形文字过渡，向不知道的人解释一下，变形文字过渡所做的是，如果你有两张文本非常相似的幻灯片，但两者之间有一些变化，变形文字过渡会，它会显示两张幻灯片之间的文字，就像进化成彼此一样。
Maybe you have a better way of explaining it than me. Yes, sure. I will, better than me explaining it, although I will briefly. First thing I have to say is we need to wind down this part two of our conversation because I don't have a super hard stop, but I do have a hard stop-ish,
也许你有比我更好的解释方式。是的，当然。我会，比我解释得好，尽管我会简短地说明。首先我要说的是，我们需要结束我们对话的第二部分，因为我没有超级硬性的截止时间，但我确实有一个硬性截止时间——
and I definitely wanna get to the stay tuned to next week listener. You know what super hard stop but I do have a hard stop ish and I definitely want to get to the Stay tuned to next week listener. You know what my hard stop is my hard stop is after a certain hour I will be unable to park anywhere in downtown San Jose Well, we'll put our hard cap at 30 minutes from now. So if we want a 25 minute part three We've got to wrap this up in five minutes. So And I have I have like four questions We're gonna have to rapid fire and then you get like 15 seconds per answer
我绝对想留到下周的听众。你知道什么超级硬性截止时间，我有一个硬性截止时间，我绝对想留到下周的听众。你知道我的硬性截止时间是什么吗？我的硬性截止时间是过了某个小时后，我将无法在圣何塞市中心的任何地方停车。好吧，我们把硬性上限设在 30 分钟后。所以如果我们想要一个 25 分钟的第三部分，我们必须在 5 分钟内结束。所以，我有四个问题，我们要快速回答，然后你每个回答有 15 秒时间，
and maybe we'll revisit this topic. So I have my third most popular YouTube video is how to use basically morph because it's the number one question I got. Welcome to the club. It's been here since 2019. You're only half a decade late and it's the most beautiful thing ever.
也许我们会重温这个话题。所以我有我的第三大热门 YouTube 视频是如何使用变形过渡，因为这是我收到的第一个问题。欢迎加入俱乐部。它从 2019 年就在这里了。你只晚了半个十年，这是有史以来最美妙的事情。
There's three different versions. Objects, the default, words is the second setting and characters. So most people don't know how to use it effectively for code because they leave it set to the default option of objects and that does nothing for your code. You have to change it to words. And yes, it basically just automatically finds the closest number of words. It's magical. And also that little hack that you sent me. I've I've watched basically this morph not keynote, but presentation where you can do crazy things with it even more than what you showed me.
有三个不同的版本。对象（默认）、文字（第二个设置）和字符。所以大多数人不知道如何有效地将其用于代码，因为他们将其保留为对象的默认选项，这对你的代码没有任何作用。你必须将其更改为文字。是的，它基本上只是自动找到最接近的字数。这很神奇。还有你发给我的那个小技巧。我已经看过基本上这个变形——不是主题演讲，而是演示，你可以用它做比你向我展示的更疯狂的事情。
So I've been a morph pro. In fact, I don't want to name the person at Microsoft, but a very senior person at Microsoft one time emailed me and asked, how are you doing that in PowerPoint? And I was like, brah, you work for Microsoft, like email the PowerPoint team. But wait, take 15 seconds, 15 seconds for whatever you're going to say, because we got a rapid fire questions after this. Do I know what? Do you know anything about the algorithm that they use to do the matching? No, but I would love to talk to the PowerPoint folks. I imagine it's just kind of some like closest thing, because it does some weird stuff every once in a while. But if
我一直是个 Morph（平滑切换）高手。事实上，我不想透露微软那位人士的名字，但有一次，一位微软的高层给我发邮件，问我：你在 PowerPoint 里是怎么做到的？我当时心想，老兄，你在微软工作，去问 PowerPoint 团队啊。不过等等，给你 15 秒，不管你想说什么都行，因为接下来我们要进行快问快答。我知道什么？你知道他们用来匹配的算法吗？不知道，但我很想和 PowerPoint 的人聊聊。我猜大概就是某种“最邻近”算法之类的，因为它偶尔会搞出一些奇怪的效果。但是如果
you work for Microsoft and you know or happen to work on that algorithm, get in touch with us. I usually block anyone that emails me asking to be a guest, but we're reaching out this time. So I'll briefly say the thing that I love the most about the morph transition is nothing about the visual itself. It's about the structure of the code. I used to, if I had a progression of code evolutions, it used to like where there was different things on different slides, it used to be that I would add additional new lines and additional spacing so that when I went from one slide to another slide, elements would stay in the same place. And that meant that if you looked at the first code slide in one
你在微软工作，或者恰好参与了那个算法的开发，请联系我们。我通常会屏蔽所有发邮件要求上节目的请求，但这次我们主动出击。所以，我简单说一下我最喜欢 Morph 过渡效果的一点，这与视觉效果本身无关，而是关于代码结构。以前，如果我有一系列代码演进过程，由于不同幻灯片上有不同的内容，我通常会添加额外的空行和间距，以便在从一张幻灯片切换到另一张时，元素能保持在相同的位置。这意味着如果你看其中一个
of these evolutions, the spacing would be all weird and unnatural. And the meant that if you saw, if you looked at the first code slide in one of these evolutions, the spacing would be all weird and unnatural. And the thing that I love about Morph is that with Morph, I don't have to do that because with Morph, if I need to insert a line at the top of the code in the next slide, what Morph will do is it will gracefully shift all the code down. I don't like it if it's jarring. If like one slide it's nine lines of code, and then the next slide those same nine lines of code
演进过程的第一张代码幻灯片，间距会显得非常奇怪且不自然。我喜欢 Morph 的地方在于，有了它，我就不必那样做了。因为有了 Morph，如果我需要在下一张幻灯片的代码顶部插入一行，Morph 会优雅地将所有代码向下移动。我不喜欢那种突兀的感觉。如果一张幻灯片有九行代码，而下一张幻灯片还是那九行代码，
are there, but they've moved down one line because I've inserted a tenth line of code in front. I don't like that. So what I would do is on the nine lines of code slide, I would put a blank line at the top. And now I don't need to do that because now with morph it will just Beautifully just shift everything down and that that is that is for me the killer feature All right, it's very graceful and we've used up three of our five minutes left in this episode folks
但因为我在前面插入了第十行代码，它们向下移动了一行，我不喜欢那样。所以我以前的做法是，在九行代码的幻灯片顶部放一个空行。现在我不需要那样做了，因为有了 Morph，它会自动且完美地将所有内容向下平移，这对我来说是杀手级功能。好了，它非常优雅，而且我们在这集剩下的五分钟里已经用掉了三分钟了，各位。
So maybe I'll limit myself to one question and you have 30 seconds to answer the number one thing That I was confused in your talk How come MVC++ and Stoodpar didn't get mentioned as a CUDA C++? I hope this isn't breaking news that that technology has been backburnered or something. What's the reason for not mentioning it? Not that it's been backburnered, just that we wanted to give a talk about how to do CUDA programming. Stdpar is great. It's not in any way something that we don't support. We certainly want people to be using it, but we wanted to give a talk about if you want to write CUDA code.
所以也许我限制自己只问一个问题，你有 30 秒的时间回答。我最困惑的一点是，为什么在你的演讲中没有提到 MVC++ 和 stdpar 作为 CUDA C++ 的一部分？我希望这不算什么爆炸性新闻，说这项技术被搁置了之类的。不提它的原因是什么？并不是因为它被搁置了，只是我们想做一个关于如何进行 CUDA 编程的演讲。Stdpar 很棒，我们绝不是不支持它。我们当然希望人们使用它，但我们想做的是关于“如果你想写 CUDA 代码”的演讲。
Like how should you write idiomatic CUDA C++ code? And I think part of the problem is that people that consider themselves CUDA programmers, they don't think that a talk about C++ standard parallelism is for them, right? So we wanted to reach a particular audience. And so this talk is, or the whole curriculum that our colleagues Georgi of Tushenko and much of this talk is based on material that Georgi made for the tutorial.
比如你应该如何编写地道的 CUDA C++ 代码？我认为部分问题在于，那些自认为是 CUDA 程序员的人，他们不认为关于 C++ 标准并行性的演讲适合他们，对吧？所以我们想触达特定的受众。因此，这次演讲，或者说我们同事 Georgi Of Tushenko 编写的整个课程，大部分内容都是基于 Georgi 为教程准备的材料。
So I can't take too much credit for it. But Georgi proposed that we shouldn't start teaching people the low level things. The way that you typically teach CUDA is you start off by teaching people about kernels and device code and separate host and device memory and warps and blocks. This talk doesn't mention warps or blocks once. In this talk, I only talk about distinct host and device memory in the last part of the talk. Right? I introduce the idea that there's different CPU and GPU memory as the last part of the talk, right? I introduce the idea that there's different
所以我不能居功自傲。但 Georgi 建议我们不应该从教人们底层知识开始。通常教授 CUDA 的方式是先教人们内核（kernels）、设备代码、分离的主机和设备内存、线程束（warps）和线程块（blocks）。这次演讲一次都没有提到线程束或线程块。在这次演讲中，我只在最后一部分谈到了独立的主机和设备内存。对吧？我把存在不同的 CPU 和 GPU 内存这一概念作为演讲的最后一部分引入，对吧？我引入了存在不同的
CPU and GPU memory as the last thing. And I don't even say the word kernel anywhere in here really. I just talk about launching work on the GPU. And Georgie came up with this idea that we should teach people to use libraries first, to use abstractions first. to use libraries first, to use abstractions first, use libraries first, try that out, use the things like thrust first and then you know only as a more advanced topic would you go and write your own kernel. You should only do that if you've tried to use the libraries and the libraries haven't worked for you because honestly you're going to get better performance if you use the abstractions. And so if you think about how do you just teach like modern C++ versus C. Well the way that people teach modern C++ is like you don't start with teaching them pointers, right?
CPU 和 GPU 内存这一概念作为最后的内容。我甚至在这里根本没提“内核”这个词。我只是谈论在 GPU 上启动工作。Georgi 想出了一个主意，我们应该先教人们使用库，先使用抽象。先使用库，先使用抽象，先使用库，试一试，先使用像 Thrust 这样的东西，然后，你知道，只有作为更高级的主题，你才会去编写自己的内核。你应该只有在尝试了库但库无法满足你的需求时才这样做，因为老实说，如果你使用抽象，你会获得更好的性能。所以，如果你思考一下如何教授现代 C++ 与 C 语言的区别，人们教授现代 C++ 的方式是，你不会从教他们指针开始，对吧？
You don't start teaching them pointers and C-style arrays. The way that I've seen people teach modern C++ to beginners these days is you start off by teaching them the standard start off by teaching them the standard library, by teaching them containers. You only introduce the notion of pointers much later on. And that's what we're trying to do with CUDA C++ here is we are teaching the content from the high level to the low level instead of from the low level to the high level. And I had two instructors during GTC come up to me and they were like, wow, this is
你不会从教他们指针和 C 风格数组开始。我最近看到人们教初学者现代 C++ 的方式是，你从教他们标准库开始，从教他们容器开始。你只在很久之后才引入指针的概念。这就是我们在这里尝试用 CUDA C++ 做的事情，我们是从高层到底层来教授内容，而不是从底层到高层。在 GTC 大会期间，有两位讲师找到我，他们说：哇，这真是
really surprising. This is a very different way of teaching. And one of them, he sort of like asked this to me and then just paused as if he expected me to say something like, oh no, this isn't how you should actually teach it. And I was just like, yeah, no, like that's what we want you to do. And he just paused and he just processed. And he was clearly, he was expecting me to say something to make him feel reassured that he didn't have
太令人惊讶了。这是一种非常不同的教学方式。其中一个人，他问了我这个问题，然后停顿了一下，好像他期待我说点什么，比如“哦不，这其实不是你应该教它的方式”。而我只是说：“是的，没错，这就是我们希望你做的。”他停顿了一下，消化了这个信息。很明显，他期待我说些什么来让他感到安心，让他觉得他不需要
to completely rethink how he was teaching this material. And then he realized that, no, wait, you really are telling me to completely rethink how I've been teaching this material. And that's exactly what we want. We wanna teach from the high level to the low level. An amazing answer, if too long. telling me to completely rethink how I've been teaching this material and that's exactly what we want. We want to teach from the high level to the low level. An amazing answer if too long.
完全重新思考他教授这些材料的方式。然后他意识到，不，等等，你确实是在让我完全重新思考我教授这些材料的方式。而这正是我们想要的。我们想从高层到底层进行教学。一个很棒的回答，如果太长的话。确实是在让我完全重新思考我教授这些材料的方式，而这正是我们想要的。我们想从高层到底层进行教学。一个很棒的回答，如果太长的话。
We have now exceeded our threshold and I have follow up stuff but we're going to table this. Remember I asked about MVC++. We're going to revisit MVC++ which the short version of what Bryce said is this was a CUDA C++ talk, MVC++ is ISO C++ with, you know, inherent or automatic parallelism. A topic for another day, and I did have questions about the universal vector and unified memory, but we will table those questions for a follow-up discussion.
我们现在已经超过了时间限制，我还有后续的问题，但我们要先搁置一下。记得我问过 MVC++ 吗？我们将重新讨论 MVC++，Bryce 所说的简短版本是：这是一个 CUDA C++ 演讲，MVC++ 是带有固有或自动并行性的 ISO C++。这是改天再谈的话题，我确实还有关于通用向量和统一内存的问题，但我们将把这些问题留到后续讨论中。
We are now transitioning to part three because at this point, if we stop at, you know, five minutes past the half hour mark it's only going to be a 22 minute episode folks. So part three of this recording which I believe puts us on like episode 228 potentially. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions. Thanks for listening, we hope you enjoyed, and have a great day! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们现在进入第三部分，因为此时如果我们停在半小时后五分钟的位置，这集只有 22 分钟，各位。所以这是录音的第三部分，我相信这让我们进入了第 228 集左右。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 adspthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天！这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。